we're joined Now by Chris gunnis a
former spokesman for the UN relief and
works agency and he's joining us live
from London Mr Gunners thank you very
much for your time you have spent time
in Gaza and our correspondent in Gaza
was just telling us about the latest
attack on a un school what goes through
your mind when you hear of these attacks
that are still taking place years
later the word that Springs to mind is
accountability there has to be
accountability because in the past we've
seen investigations and it's led to
nothing but now we have the
international criminal court which has
an investigation into what is going on
uh we have other Justice mechanisms
around the world which can be activated
what I would like to see is an
independent a free and a fair
investigation into all of these crimes
and they are international crimes being
committed on both sides so on the Hass
side we saw what happened on the 7th of
October we've seen what's happened since
um as a result of the bombardment by the
Israelis and I would like to see
accountability because in 2014 for
example we had a board of inquiry
nothing happened um we had other
examinations other reports and there's
been no action we now have a substantive
difference the ICC and other
jurisdictions are involved and we need
to see criminal accountability we need
to see those leaders on both sides
brought to book and that will deal with
extremists and once that's happened we
need to see the moderates come forward
because make no mistake there can only
be a negotiated settlement military
Victory is simply not possible so we
have to make sure that this pause is
built on so that there is a lasting
ceasefire because for every day
bombardment that goes past the chances
of a negotiated peace settlement Israel
living in security the Palestinians
having their own State the prospects for
that recede every single day and about
the ceasefire how much do you think that
this ceasefire alone this 4-day
ceasefire can help people
there well it can make a difference I
mean let's be clear 200 Aid trucks per
day and is it two or four fuel trucks
that's a drop in the ocean that's never
going to be enough so this pause Call It
Whatever You Will has to be turned into
something permanent because the stakes
are simply too high you've got 80% of
the G is strip made homeless and
displaced you've got hundreds of
thousands of homes in the north
completely flattened so we have to see
an extended ceasefire in which there is
rapid ramping up of the humanitarian and
development operation because you know
after the 2014 um operation I think
people said between 10 and 15% of the
ordinance is unexploded that has to be
cleared we have to see the rubble
cleared we have to see a massive ramping
up of the effort because to be clear the
alternative is Unthinkable it's a
massive humanitarian crisis involving
two million people and the potential
Mass displacement into Egypt goodness
knows where and at that point the
prospects for peace and the prospect of
Israel living in a secure State frankly
Falls over a cliff for for any of this
to happen the two sides will need to
further agree Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin nany who had said that he
wouldn't negotiate with Hamas yet here
we are on the eve of a ceasefire and
captives release reach through
intermediaries if the two sides can get
here do you believe they can go
further of course I do and we have to
believe that I mean Mr Netanyahu said he
was going to destroy Hamas and here we
are within weeks him negotiating with
Hamas I mean let's get real folks the
two sides know they have to talk to each
other and yes of course with the qataris
putting pressure on Hamas with the
Americans putting pressure on the
Israelis a 4-day pause can turn into a
5-day pause during which a further 10
hostages will be released as apparently
has been agreed this pause can be
extended into something positive the
momentum of the conflict can be the
momentum can be taken out of the
conflict and that will afford an
opportunity for confidence building
measures the two sides to talk to each
other because as I say there can be no
military Victory we have to see this
hostage negotiation as something which
will lead to a further negotiation
something which ultimately could perhaps
lead to more substantive peace talks
that has to be the hope tonight because
the alternative is too appalling to
consider the alternative is Israel
living in a state of insecurity all of
the policies since 67 build a wall
around the Palestinians oppose an
apartate system on the Palestinians
control them that's not worked and on
the 7th of October that Genie
disappeared it was shown to be the
Shamira it always was those policies
have failed to give Israel the security
it craves and by the way on the
Palestinian side they have to realize
that they can only get their state by
talking to the Israelis Israelis get
security by talking to Hamas and the
other side and the and the Palestinian
side will get a state I think that the
events of the last weeks have proven
that that is frankly the only thing to
pursue because the alternative is just
too ghastly to contemplate that is the
former spokesman for the UN relief and
works agent see Chris Gunners joining us
live from London thank you very much for
your time my
pleasure